and the spirit award for best new  scripted series  goes to  i may destroy you  [Music]  thank you to the independent spirit  awards for the best new scripted series  award  it is an honor to receive this and i  accept it on behalf  of the full i may destroy you team i  thank every single person that helped us  make the show  piers amy and amy my producing partner  phil clark  my incredible cast my co-director sam  miller  and my edit team we worked tirelessly  through lockdown to edit this show  and through a very very hard political  climate last year there was a global  pandemic there was racism there was  polarization  and police brutality and it felt really  nice to have a team  that i could join on zoom and just  express love  to one another day in day out so thank  you  i believe that all of our dna is in this  show  so thank you very much to you and this  award is yours  thank you  you